so Detroit able to kill off the first Power
Play of the night and now with speed Kane
moves in wrist shot that hit the post oh Kane
has drawn iron multiple times sad joins the
battle as well Bush navic frees it up cre wrist
shot that trickles just wide haramed in front so
may have gotten a piece B davich again side of
the net side score B davich to side the first
goal of this ESPN Hockey Night double header
belongs to the blues they've got a one- nothing
lead St Louis Blues had some crisp passes
on this one and they were certainly able to
change the point of attack several times and
this gets up to toy crew the Michigan State
spart and gets through deflected but doesn't
find the mark But winning a Bo battle is key
that's C who does a great job of extending that
stationed off that back po post Leno tied up by
faul that is cleared and moving in butcha short
handed to the for hand it on the backand thato
stayed home and kicked the left pad out just
ins time that looked like a wide open goal top
pass out in front bad save made by Bennington
at the opposite end the rebound score Walman
the defenseman down low is able to roof it past
Bennington after a this golden opportunity at
the other end for St Louis we Todd at one action
a plenty and that Trend continues in this game
here come the wings with speed little Zone entry
and kick it out to the right flank little stop
up play and puts it toward net Jordan vinon
made the first save which is an outstanding
one but you see his momentum holds off the big
defenseman controlling the puck with one arm
Rass M into the corner to bron bron Center
one wrist shot had hit the post the rebound
score Jonathan berren does it again he scored a
couple of times since rejoining the Detroit Red
Wings now and the wings have a two one Le by the
Detroit Red Wings on this shift it's rasmon on the
entry holding off the defender Paro on his back
difficult to do two big men on that matchup and
then it's a little quick play to strong who get
it up high to the point and there's that second
effort by Jonathan bergren but this one Rings Iron
by Petri and you'll see the bounce right into the
feet good kept alive Well Done by kro to kick
it down to his stick and Now controls hich look
for the C that save made BYO it looked like Shen
put it right on the pad of Billy huso guided in
along the near glass sherat looking to reverse the
same way all was waiting for it he'll leave it for
cop at his pocket picked by K turned back by Ka
across the line Cas Barry Ka slides the pass out
in front T by side and that's denied by Billy
husa neutral zone they need to tighten on some
Gap and they told the team between periods in the
defensive Zone you got to be more physical Well
you certainly want that chemistry shot SC ready
deflected in front it looked like Kevin Hayes they
have gotten a piece off the Blast by Hayes with
the ti in and that ties the game at two to this
point in the game and now we've got a critical
face off in the wings D Zone ozone for the blues
and really simple but effective win the draw clean
get net front shot from lety and it's Hayes who's
unchecked left all alone he's a big man to reach
and soft man to two a piece Paro at the right
Point sweeps one towards the Neto fall it off
with the blocker and now more cider pitch fors
one up not out he shoots SC two goals that quickly
for Kevin Hayes and just like that it's a 3-2 St
Louis leag it is a game of mistakes we know that
but the wings were in possession nice battling
by the wings very good dzone posture and then
a giveaway leads to this one right here you've
got the puck here and it's the ever steady mider
who just kind of fans on that backhand attempt
and in comes Kevin Hayes known for his passing
intercepted by Faulk and left for perunovich
behind the net an outlet pass and neighbors
skates it free tape for tape across the line
ful Mo save made and the rebound carries behind
the net back up top there gets a return across to
Kane Kane right back to Raymond a one-time shot
pass on Nick save right on the edge of the blue
paint T Racing for it and sunquist was there to
help out Bennington crew Gathers at rtier locked
on the way in by cider possible three on two Ras
mus across the line around F centering pass on the
edge of the paint poked score Cider on the rebound
right in front of Bennington and we're tied to
three mistake and we know most Siders is
outstanding a really good young defenseman
and here come the wings on the attack put the puck
to the net simple there's cider who follows this
one up as Jordan Von's down prone but it's Ras M
who puts it to the net off the paddle in essence
that becomes a shot off missing David pan because
of suspension yeah two of their key offensive cogs
and of course z Lin the captain multi Allstar and
David pan one to Stanley Cup here in St Louis down
low tries to stop at home sto by Bennington
pain controls across to De brinken onetime
got to spare and The Twig snaps in half and that
allows scandel a breakway shorthanded who into the
back wow what a turn of events for the St Louis
Blues given some FY equipment and Thomas with a
great short-handed look at the opposite end once
again as it's played back to Gaspar at the point
Detroit getting things set up on the power play
Kane down low into the bumper score Lucas Raymond
off the one touch from valeno and we're tied at
four a power play goal for the Red Wings under a
minute into the third period and it really is
quick touches here a little stop up watch the
right of your screen though 23 and white see
him get to the middle that's Lucas Raymond he
timesed his route perfectly and he gets there
and it is that bump pass Peru from voleno out
to Rayman open your verners take a sip it's 44
wings with the equalizer the 50th career goal
for Lucas floats off his stick to olimat Justin
Hall Once Again gains the red line once again
softly ahead this time handled by cop Raymond
slips at the Pucket goes behind the net the cop
gets it right back to Raymond centering and Scar
fabry found the puck through traffic he beat Prue
in front the One Touch gives the wings a 54 lead
are able to generate a real good one nice entry
I just mentioned placing pucks where you have
a chance to recover second effort here by the
wings get underneath the goal line and you'll
see momentarily it's Robbie fabry who comes off
the bench guess who's back back again Robbie
fabry back in St Louis behind the net valeno
the first to it kyou trying to fight to keep it
on side belenos all over him takes the puck away
and clears towards the empty net rmon got to in
for an empty net short-handed goal after terrific
work by Joe valeno along the boards and Joey
voleno number 90 watch him get to the spot This
Is The Stuff coaches and Scouts look for he's
pestering kyou he's pounding kyou he's got the
weed whacker around in the front line and sends
this one the distance and is capped off by Ras
new but all made possible by the blue collar no
question man oh man was just a hard fought game by
both these squads tons of offense but it's Billy
husto in his return Robbie fabry in his return